peu
[Musique]
oh
pourquoi
mais n'est donc pas peur coup elle est
faite on s'en sortir oui on allait oui
un bête
allez allez allez on fait toujours mais
c'est bel et bien quitter la loire les
entrepôts les autres tu ne sais pas que
monsieur et madame s'en sortit aller
happer fourneaux la place d'une
cuisinière n'est pas dans l'appartement
les pousse au canada avec des femmes
si vous ne l'aimez pas c'est elle qui
nous mène je ne mange pas de pain à la
brebis
voyez comme c'est le docteur cette
petite femme là c'est un caniche pour la
fidélité mais c'est un petit groupe pour
la jalousie elle est toujours à fouiner
dans l'appartement assure pour mes pieds
il a dû surmonter le job à cause de la
femme de chambre à elle s'est montée le
jeu pas vous demande un peu moi une
camériste aux comores
mais c'était pas tous assez puisque
monsieur défenseur messin de cheria j'ai
le temps je t'aimerai compagnie à
messieurs certainement c'est très
aimable et répondre mais je craindrais
d'abuser du tout du tout je n'ai rien
pressés alors et vous ne savez pas
quelle heure ils pas rentrés monsieur où
passent avant un gros quart d'heure un
diable et bien écouté puisque c'est
comme ça et quelques agréments que
j'aurais à rester avec vous monsieur le
flat l'île du tout du tout du tout
seulement on n'est pas dans la ville
uniquement pour s'amuser fille géant
malade avoir prédit si je vais
l'expliquer c'est trop non non l'entente
des non merci il déchets du manager
tiens c'est mon fonds de commerce
non j'ai expliqué ma visite et je suis
de retour dans un quart d'heure j'aurais
landaise grâce à un système donc
désobligeants
on rentre dans mon tour vous lui
remettrez ça vous dirait que j'ai
examiné le client qu'il m'envoyait ce
qu'il est en parfaite état il peut
l'assurer en toute confiance à moi aussi
seulement qu'est ce que vous voulez ça
intéresse mais chez le directeur pour
paris et la province de napo stade
livecompare le patron en quoi un d'entre
nous soit le patron puisque vous le
permettez eh bien vous me direz que les
solides algo les premières places
comment dit-on carlos medidata distingue
wade michaud se distendre american est
justement sa femme nadia temps madame
dans le salon nous comme le monde
j'ai examiné son mari ce matin et sa
femme est là qu on était 5 ou 6 en
matinée si tous les deux la frontière si
vous me dites pas d'acteur puisque je
vous tiens au ce qui me plaît chez vous
c'est que vous n'êtes pas en arrière
mais pourquoi serais-je non non je
voulais vous demander parce que on en
cause et ce matin avec madame
marchandises a non pas la patronne
madame à moins avec ma propre famille
oui enfin madame votre femme ce n'est
pas respectueux possible ayant cantona
comme ça de mercier vous je vous en prie
il va continuer comme ça de chaque côté
du pont entre comme un point continuelle
mot revient souvent des ovaires à
hebinger samoa un hors bord on n'a ni
pour vous les faire enlever en un nom je
les fais je regarde homme est reparti
pour garçons que je ne vous les demandes
pour vous pourriez
vous êtes souvent de change différents
os sur madame madame quand même bien
recommander si matane non enfin le nom
badaoui nominé deux destins goy c'est ça
et bien tenir jeudi à tunis a fait
parfaitement
ne la laissez pas s'en allait j'ai
absolument besoin d'avoir du fruit c'est
ce qu'elle m'a écrit c'est même pour ça
que je suis étonné ce qu'on fait je vais
attendre encore un peu mais ne sait
jamais justement je conversais avec
mesure oui nous conversons de
personnages le médecin en chef de la
bostonnais de compagnie qui me disait
qu'il avait vu le mari madame ce matin a
longtemps douté c'est exact madame j'ai
eu l'honneur d'examiner monsieur de
liste en quoi ces faits examinés ce sont
les petites indiscrétions de toutes les
compagnies d'assurances mais je me
félicite madame vous avez un mari une
santé à tempérament monsieur à qui le
dites-vous
oui monsieur mais c'est fatiguant on n'a
rien sans peine coin et dire tout voilà
ce que ray pour la peluche qui savent
même plus où les poules signal qui me
fait toujours bon dos
il lui faudrait un homme comme le mari
de madame est bien mais avec
l'autorisation valable et le
consentement de monsieur de liste en
quoi il y aurait peut-être un moyen
d'arranger ça ricane non petit temps
docteur mais moi non pardon c'est cette
garde le week-end qui me paye rdv dû
allonger le souffle
si je vais être amené dans un quart
d'heure madame enchanté et sans repère
vient me dire ce que nous disions tout à
l'heure de terre quand je m'appuie comme
sa maison-mère apprenait dans une bonne
ambiance en scène à cannes en mai
1h07
c'est sacrément d'apple maintenant avec
impatience
coffe et unique album light me up à
amatan comme en asie et non en outre que
les internautes ont pâti à hama je vous
demande pardon mais je ne comprends pas
bien ce que vous me dites on la rbq a à
maintes et bien méritant d'un tonneau
non monsieur je suis française
oui fait mouche en choisit alors si vous
voulez vous adresser aux valets de
chambre je ne suis pas de la maison
j'attends madame chandebise avec qui
jean rendez-vous laurent gbagbo au nom
de la compagnie oui monsieur ou l'avant
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
d'aller me dit tu viens d'entrer ici un
an
il m'a parlé à g je ne sais pas trop ce
qui m'a raconté oh oh oh wow niveau 1
aux règles sont comme ça
cette chicane étrangers pour lui pas du
tout c'est le nobel monsieur le propre
fils de son frère et son neveu germain
toit a bien je comprends comme
d'habitude la peine il a un vice de
prononciation madame il ne peut pas
prononcer les consonnes alors c'est même
très gênant quand on n'est pas habitué
moi je commence à comprendre vous est
donné dès sont ainsi passés mais à force
d'entendre n'est ce pas l'oreille
alors monsieur larry comme secrétaire et
comme il pouvait se passer d'une part à
cause sans votre respect de s'afficher
passant de parents d'un jeune homme qui
naquit voyelles à vous offrir
ben oui c'est pas rasées je sais bien qu
en l'écrivant il donne aussi les
consoles mais enfin on peut pas toujours
écrire pas vrai ah c'est bien dommage a
dit un garçon si sérieux six rangées
si je vous disais madame qu'on ne lui
connaît pas de détresse a longtemps à
moi du moins bien il est bien le jeune
aurier madame plus désolé matois
laissez-nous etienne madame excuses en
grèce gfr temps ratée c'est une bavure
une constat nos matelas sacs lucienne si
je t'ai écrit venir c'est une seule
parcelle
mon mari me trompait victor émanerait
victor-emmanuel parfaitement au
printemps je vous connais ça dans
l'estomac le misérable omegle pascal
créé un sommet qui n'attend pas la fin
mais non je n'ai pas le nord mais j'en
aurais je ne sais pas tu es là tu la
trouveras nancy ne dit pas non plus hier
c'était ma meilleure amie
nous avons beau nous être perdus pendant
dix ans il ya des choses qui ne sait pas
par cet équidé lucienne bicart jeudi
retrouvez lucienne homelidays de vista
en bois ton nom a pu s'allonger
mettons que vais rester le même j'ai
dans le droit de thé considérait
toujours comme m'améliorer en hausse à
faire c'est le cas toi que je le droit
d'avoir recours quand j'ai un service a
demandé c'est bien bon et je remercie
bon alors dit moi qu'est ce que tu dois
faire et pour passer mon mari non
seulement des ventes et qui m'a fait ni
mais oui on veut d'abord qu'est-ce qui
te prouve qu'il n'est pas ça le combat
il s'est peut-être le plus fidèle des
épreuves dames puisque tu n'as pas la
preuve il ya des choses qui ne trompe
pas justement ton mari et peut-être de
sel la rage os x lion ayant faim dans le
monde
mais qu'est ce que tu fais toi si plus
du monde nos maris la preuve vétérane
mari un mari enfin marie mois s'est
brusquement de l'être l'asblanc du jour
au lendemain loire je dirais ouf le
savons d'avancé sont là aussi figure 3
cet amour continue ce printemps par
tonne je trouvais ça fastidieux
l'automne viseo un nuage
une contrariété un souci quelque chose
devait arriver à songer à prendre le
mans y allons montrer qu'il en soit la
plus clémente avait déjà jeté mon dévolu
aux émotions maternelle pour ne pas
mener avec east effet d'inhérent tient
sa méthode une femme a été admise par
candice heck
c'est le plus actif ami de mon mari il
se trouvait naturellement tout désigné
pour on met maintenant plus souvent que
je le prendrais un amant maintenant que
mon mari me trompe mais tu que je te
dise moi donc tu es folle de ton mari
folle mois ou
alors qu'est ce que cette fin que ça
m'agace alors je vais bien encore le
tromper mais qu'il me trompe lui
alors non ça ça n'est pas moi je n'ai
pas ici seulement voilà tout ce que tu
m'expose ne pouvait rien comment pouvait
on ya un mois non mais quant à marie est
écolo 10 anni le torrent impétueux et
que puisque mme en plus rien à sec
ben oui le mondial mais c'est comme ça
ça ne prouve pas qu'il se détourne de
son livre parce que tu n'as pas vu
souvent dans les casinos des gens et
thonon la galerie par le reste aux mains
couvertes et qu'on trouve quelque temps
après jour la pièce de centres précis
seulement il a joué la pièce de son
sumériens il est le monsieur qui tourne
autour de la table bien raison plus
simple pour pas qu'ils se décapent
ailleurs sa propre seulement qu'il ait
des caves et un point c'est tout ouidah
et vice à eau
qu'est ce que c'est que ça des trois
thèmes et c'est bien ce qui me semble et
ctu à quelles sont ses bretelles thomas
risch près de là tu vois qu'il ne défend
déjà plusieurs noms ont maintenant je
dis cela parce que je suppose que si tu
as des bretelles sur toile sont plutôt à
ton mari qu un autre monsieur
parfaitement et qui vous dit m'expliquer
maintenant comment il se fait qu'il les
ait reçu ce matin par la poste ces
protéines la porte à un colis postal que
j'ai ouvert par mégarde en inspectant
son courrier pour qu'on respecte et eu
son courrier pour savoir ce que ça c'est
une raison et c'est ça que tu appelles
ouvrir un tollé par les gars me donne
par mes gars signifie qu'ils ne
mettaient pas à presser
mathurin pas les traditions nous
renvoyait ses bretelles par la poste
c'est apparemment qu'il les avait
oubliés quelque part il est évident mais
c'est tout cas la thèse soit quelque
part qui me fait peur l'hôtel du minet
galant machel qu'est ce que c'est que ça
comme son nom l'indiqué par une pension
de famille bien sûr loutil du mines
eagle tiens d'ailleurs voici la boîte de
l'emploi de voir l'étiquette s'est
imprimée est en dessous le nom et
l'adresse de mon mari monsieur showbiz
95 par matra hôtel du mit légal et à
montretout ma chère encore un nom qui en
dit long bord je répète tout les
inconvenance ont fait n'y a pas d'erreur
mon côté nec classement
jusqu'à présent j'avais bien des doutes
en voyant mon mari un peu un peu et
manzanares
je me disais bien et bains les bains un
cadeau mais alors ça ça alors ça m'a mis
la puce à l'oreille comme si tu voyais
c'est ton père ma chère ils allaient
ressortir le confiseur comment si tu
voyais tu le connais de naturellement
champignons mais c'est pour ça que
j'étais en retard mais j'ai voulu en
avoir le coeur net
je me suis dit il n'y a qu'un moyen
interrogé le talent sied bien si tu
crois qu'on interroge comme ça à chaud
nanciers c'est effrayant ce qu on se
soutient dans le vie s'achève et n'a
rien voulu savoir
dams et la bc du métier une telle
épreuve dotée ne sais pas ce qu'il m'a
dit non mais madame si je divulguais le
nom des gens qui fréquentent mon hôtel
mais vous seriez la première année
jamais ri y a pas eu moyen de tirer
davantage de jean caron et ça tue la
nabli cours aussi je vois que ma voix
compter que sur nous mêmes
les hommes se soutiennent entre eux il
faut que nous en fassions autant tuer
plus débrouillards et moi qui connais
les faits
qu'est ce que ce soit fait aux médias tu
me prend au dépourvu mais voyous et
l'éclair de génie oui anges c'est bien
la voyons s'il y avait une explication
avec ton mari de toi vous dis ça je
pense bien qu'il me répondrait par un
mensonge il ya des moteurs comme un
homme jeune et une femme
il ya peut-être moyen que j'ai vus
servir son côté aaa n'est pas génial
enfin avec les hommes voilà on prend une
feuille de papier à lettres bien parti
on écrit une lettre à son arc une lettre
brûlants comme si c'était du no 3 5 bien
entendu et on termine en lui donnant un
rodez vous rendez vous auquel on la
semaine allait naturellement s'il
m'arrive bien on est fixé oui oui tu as
raison c'est tellement génial mais c'est
ça se développe dans les bois ya les
plus classiques qui est venu nous allons
tout de suite dit reconnaître à mon
écriture
si tu lui as déjà écrit c'est certain la
tienne elle a fait n'est pas toi mon
toit du palais non non non non non salon
s'annonce être délicat et ben voilà tout
je fais appel à la délicatesse ait eu ma
meilleure ennemie ou ne les tue pas on
écoute toi qui ont conduit rendant fait
remarquer pouvoir et granby en france
benoît du club pierre et voilà tiers non
mais pas celui-là c'est le tien il le
reconnaître je suis pas de ces vrais
attend du papier que j'avais acheté pour
les enfants de ma soeur pour le
compliment car on y croira qu'il a à
faire une cuisinière il me répond c'est
vrai quand tu n'as pas du papier suave
suggestif j'ai bien ce mot je venais de
lâcheté pour la campagne mais il n'est
pas très suggestions enfants appartenant
fortement au un certain trèfle incarnat
que j'avais mis de côté pour le rendre
elles n'ont pas encore de l aluminium
il m'a mis fin au contrat préfères tu
peux maintenant alors je pense qu'il ne
peut guère tarder on est à vendre
abdoul bâ et bora ou te le dirai bien
évidemment là pourquoi me regardent
comme ça rien pour rien eh bien à vous
déterminer par an en effet monsieur je
vous reconnais nous allons même poser
ensemble tout à l'heure ce n'est pas ça
qui te parlent ils te dis que j'ai tout
de même fini par entrer que je n'étais
pas c'est trop patent et à monsieur
camille 119 crise est malin carlos émis
l'idée de listes ont eu droit à deux
essieux
oui excusez moi si je ne vous ai pas
compris tout à l'heure je suis un peu
dur d'oreille qatar a hérité des gones
au grand banditisme azuréen élus et aux
bleus promettant un oui oui parfaitement
il se dit qu'il a un léger défaut de
prononciation
c'est vrai oui oui maintenant vous me le
fait remarquer aux nets ont revu
il m'a poussé à démissionner mais avait
monté dans sa chambre à la fois des
films humour et satire bien aller dans
mon cabinet de toilette et rapporter
moins de poids contenant flacons ou deux
qui dans le tiroir de droit de ma
coiffeuse bien malade
il ya un trèfle incarnat a pris 1,11
une foule a écouté m'avait trouvé à
l'entrée du matisse massa est rude à
l'égard de comprendre un mot de son
langage et c'est pour ça qu'il me
regardait oui est ce que tu veux la
force de l'habitude mais je t'aime toi
qui voulais lui faire croire que tu
n'avais rien remarqué ce n'est pas je
n'aurais pas dû être désagréable voter
sa merci si vous écrivez votre lettre
avant que mon mari ne rend vous avais tu
as raison voyons comment allons-nous lui
tourné ce poulet d'abord où notre
inconnu aurait-elle reçu le coup de
foudre
oui où êtes vous allés au théâtre ces
temps ci attend mercredi dernier au
palais royal avec monsieur tournai qui
savait se tourne elle salue que teddy
kfy est mon amant aonuma ça va de mieux
qui va voir monsieur je vous ai vu
l'autre soir au théâtre du palais royal
ok tu trouves pas à bien froid pour vous
non bien fois en dragon stade messieurs
j'étais pareille somme que j'écrirais la
brutale mange je suis celle qui ne vous
à partie des deizioù l'autre soir au
palais royal
et puis il parle monsieur la comédie
dont tu as la location toi non jeudi
comme une simple que j'écris venir et
c'est bien ce que je voulais dire
alors je suis celle qui ne vous a pas
quitté les yeux
l'autre soir au palais royal est enfin
il ya assez chaud c'est dire veille
s'est vécu vous étiez dans une loge avec
votre femme et à monsieur monsieur
tournelles oui mais ça c'est pas la dame
de nias brr des gens près de moi vous en
a mais nous on le met c'est comme ça que
j'ai su qu'ils vous étiez comme ça
[Rires]
depuis ce temps je n'aurais recrues de
haut
tu crois que c'est pas un peu exagéré
non non non ça chauffe ça c'est toujours
exagérées pour les autres et jamais pour
soient pratiqués sur ces biens et 11
je suis prête à faire une folie vous
voulez vous faire avec moi je vous
attendrai aujourd'hui à 5h à l'hôtel du
minet galant
tu crois que c'est fini je suis sur les
motels un nom est donc offert salle
excitera
entre douce parenthèse scène honte
j'espère en venant vous demanderez
lâchant à moi au nom de monsieur
chandebise bien sûr et j'espère en vous
ça il y avait un fond noir
l'apprentissage une femme qui vous
aiment et maintenant aux tarterêts voilà
bah c'est du propre sapristi tout est à
recommencer maintenant on mais non bien
sûr va servir au contraire attend le
script tonnes pourquoi en vous écrivant
depuis je retenir mes larmes au fait que
ce soit des larmes de joie et non de
désespoir gagne 4,8 a beaucoup pleuré
pour une femme ça mais non ça lui
semblera tout naturel bon et maintenant
alors un peu de trac au trèfle incarnat
est maintenant une enveloppe pas alors
monsieur victor emmanuel chain ghz
victor emmanuel chain bizarre 80 cas
vous devrez verbe personnel bien sûr
faire ça et maintenant il nous faut un
commissionnaire à tuer quelqu'un pour
l'envoyer sur suite quelqu'un frontières
ah bah oui j'ai toi à moi on perd mais
non c'est pas non voyons je te préviens
domestique pour qu'il revoie le même
commissionnaires a porté la lettre de
même moi je ne peux pas y adhérer plus
c'est pas si mon mari demande le
signalement de la dame et qu'on lui
donne le mien le pot-aux-roses et
découvert la voile à toute l'école est
une âme et leur ami ou ne les crois
cabut on a sonné sa portée pour mari le
docteur vous avez qu'il repasserait oui
monsieur
bon ça va bien entre mon vieux je te
demande
vous pourriez assigné oui même camille
t'attend complice il retient la toile
bonjour ça va donner mais je suis là
j'ai rencontré tourner dans l'escalier
alors nous sommes montés ensemble oui
j'apporte la liste de quelques nouveaux
clients s'il est parfait tu veux
montrant race à tous d'aller vers un ton
pantalon cds droite elle qui te gêne
oui ça n'était pas celle que je fais à
acheter si si elle ne tenait pas avant
mais c'est parce que je les ai trop
tirer assez facile j'étais déçu et le
non non non j'ai des super bien moi même
quand il voudra super mais je suis
attendu à aa à aa mais tu es bon moi je
vais refaire alors ils m'ont répondu
j'ai rêvé de cusco non moins mignon mais
si mon mari me trompe que c'est angers
en faire autant un essai co-organisera
penser que ces choses là
réponse vous m'aviez dit m'aviez dit
jeudi espérer quand c'est possible mais
il n'y avait pas annuler moi tu n es
maintenant qu'il ya eu les boîtes l on
soit la défense l aller les bras mais
qu'est ce que ça veut dire les bretelles
on pouvait avoir pour ouvrir comme en
voit ce que vous me dites un canton qui
décidera apparaît clairement rue dans
des eaux où un ou bon mon cousin vous
demande sais pas quoi on le dit au gnouf
à membres permanents le cap et mon oeil
oui monsieur et qui est largement le lui
dis peuvent les dames en couvre l eau
on est généreux et wii party bétail et
vaincre al alami cas n'ayant reçu que
des malheurs maintenant avez vous un
coeur on raisonnera loukoum les a pas
quelqu'un finit à girl who have a drame
ou donnés par l'appel à part ça gêne
sacré qu'entre 9
en fait la seconde à oui c'est vrai si
vous passez pour l'austère camille et
vous tenez à votre réputation roulant
malheureusement quand son médecin il ya
toujours une heure dans la ville ont été
obligés de dépouiller le petit sac aussi
courtois qui sait ça m'amuse bien quand
je les vois tous imaginé que oui oui où
les dents vous allez suivi mon conseil
elle a pour l'hôtel du minet galant oui
au contrôle nous sommes entre nous vous
avez été oui qu'est ce que vous en dites
oh je vous le disais mais moi c'est bien
simple quand je veux faire la noce je te
connais que cet hôtel là oui je voulais
faire des chardons avait tonné aller
prévient m cousin et aaa pendant que j'y
pense que je vous donne votre machin l1
ce que je vous ai promis ce qui vous
permet pas de parler comme tout le monde
ou larry b oui mais pas qu'est ce qui
entrave chez vous cette faculté un vice
congénital la nuque du palais qui n'a
pas eu le temps de se former
aussi les sons au lieu de trouver cette
cloison d'intérêt qu'ils effet rebondi
odeurs vont se perdre dans le masque et
à ben c'est cette cloison que je vous
apporte un et regarder jc jolie vient
présenter voyant un palais d'argent mon
cher comme dans les contes de fées ans
et dans un écrin madame un avoir son
palais dans un écrin c'est pas la vente
et tout le monde est là et les arrêts
quoi et ouais attendait alors comme ça
non non non mais tu es le tremper dans
de l'eau avec un peu d'acide borique
hommes c'est pas dans lequel massa a
pensé à vous avez raison non mais elle
est au gua et ainsi vous pourrez parler
de commandant si même vous avez du
talent vous pourrez entrer la comédie
française avait tout de suite se mettre
dedans on reste tous les ans nous
appelle on va prôner la colombie acura
heures jamie et avoue tout de suite il a
eu affaire par là ça va bien en bonjour
finale a bien tenu alors vous je suis
content de booba justement j'avais à
vous parler mais je suis déjà venu tout
à l'heure mais qu'elle ne vaut la vie
oui oui pour le certificat de juste
envers eux il paraît même qu'il est de
premier ordre de première du reste le
voici
merci et qu'est ce que vous avez à dire
et bien voila voila je voulais vous
consulté pour moi sur une question assez
délicate
vous figurez vous qu'il m'arrive de
choses un peu extraordinaire
quoi donc comment vous expliquera
charles
vous savez que j'ai une femme délicieuse
part ça nous sommes d'accord vous savez
d'autre part que personne les moins un
coureur que votre serviteur à quoi vous
dit pas si ray je ne sais pas mon ami et
bien je vous le dis pas je ne vous
étonnerez non pas en vous confiant que
ma femme
résumé tout pour moi les pouces et la
menthe afin de se part ce qui revient à
dire que j'ai toujours été pour elle
sage je suis monté en premier un mari à
la hauteur pas auditoire 6
c'est toi mon ami et bien je vous le dis
à la hauteur et même plus c'est très
bien tout ça seulement je ne vois pas où
ce préambule mais bien voilà justement
vous avez vu jouer nouveautés vous
n'avez rien à déclarer un nom je vous
demande si vous avez vu jouer vous
n'avez rien à déclarer fait mon dieu ça
coûtait quoi vous l'avez vu vous l'avez
pas vu je vais vous dire entre les deux
hommes
je n'étais pas seul dans ma baignoire
c'était là tu vois là pouvait apprendre
vous en avez toujours assez vu pour être
au courant du sujet un bon petit jeune
homme fait son voyage de noces avec
madame il est en train de lui inculquer
les premiers principes de la grammaire
matrimoniale quant au meilleur de la
leçon surgit un douanier dont
intempestifs vous n'avez rien à déclarer
vient brutalement coupée à monsieur le
fil de ses idées mais en effet je me
rappelle vaguement vaguement même vieux
on voit bien que le douanier ne pas
penser parfois de baignoires et il n'ya
pas passé car bref c'est pas pour le
pauvre petit jeune homme dès lors ça
devient comme une obsession
chaque fois qui lui prend velléités de
réaborder avec madame la question et
c'est une première fois dans le vague il
louvoie le douanier il en taule vous
n'avez rien à déclarer et rient plus
personne
c'est embêtant car oui et bien trop cher
c'est exactement ce qui m'arrive avec ma
femme est parfaitement un bon jour je
pensais plutôt une sale nuit il ya de ça
un mois j'étais très amoureux comme à
mon habitude je m'en étais exprimé à
madame chandebise qui en avaient
aussitôt accueilli l'expression quand
tout à coup je ne sais pas ce qui a pu
se passer
le droit y est entré oui elle se doit
mais non mais non mais non non non ce n
est ce pas c'est tout comme même malaise
un trouble r je me suis senti devenir
enfant mes enfants tout petit enfant
médium ces raids
si on peut dire mon dieu moi tout
d'abord le spar je ne m'en vais mais pas
autant d'enfants de foot un passé
glorieux
je me dis revers aujourd'hui en revanche
demain c'est la guerre oui mais voilà ty
pas que le lendemain j'ai eu la
malencontreuse idée de me dire attention
mon dieu s'il fallait faire comme hier
au foot us bête pour se prouver des
choses paris en tête juste au moment où
on a besoin de toute sa confiance en soi
naturellement ça ne manque pas l'anxiété
me prend et blanc comme la veille la tap
mon pauvre chandebise la wii pour
ressembler car désormais c'est fini ça
devienne des fixes je ne me pose même
plus la question je n'ose même plus me
dire ce soir
est-ce que je je me dis ce soir je ne m
l'an celle rap mais tandis que vous
commandera nourrir nos fils à chaussures
c'est vraiment pas de me présenter au
tragique mais il est de tous les jours
votre cas il est simplement victime d'un
phénomène d'auto cie gestion
mais c'est à vous d'en avoir raison un
peu de force de caractère que diable
vouloir c'est pouvoir
mais au lieu de vous dire est ce que je
ce qui vous si chabat il faut vous dire
entre jeu et voilà jamais douté de soins
dans la vie à et surtout ne pas y mettre
d'amour propre parfum tout ça c'est de
l'amour et bien l'amour propre et
l'amour ça ne va pas ensemble et si même
il y en a un des deux qu'on appelle
propre c'est pour le distinguer de
l'autre qu'il les prend au vaincu tout
ce que vous venez de me raconter c'est à
votre femme que vous auriez dû le dit
pas à moi et cela bien nettement bien
posément au lieu d'essayer de faire le
malin avec elle serait arrivée qu'elle
en aurait ri vous en auriez ensemble
chacun y aurait mis du sien et l'émotion
l'inquiétude désormais au rancart ça
aurait marché comme sur des roulettes
oui et c'est vous souvenez vous n'avez
pas raison et en dehors de ça du sport
de l'exercice rejoints au regard des
tendances et vous
c'est pour ça que je vous ai redonné des
bretelles américaine futurs produits si
si si si si d'ailleurs pour être forcés
de les conserver j'ai même donné toutes
mes bretelles ordinaire place et c'est
mon cousin camille qui en a hérité mais
vraiment vous savez celle là c'est bien
vous êtes le seul à les voir mais non
non non tout à l'heure ma femme a failli
mettre le nez dessus
bon la belle affaire or mais reçus ne
spoile non plus que d'ajouter ce
ridicule à l'autre voila voila vous mais
dès que la vanité ne devrait pas y en
avoir retiré votre avis tout à l'heure
bouchard madame mais comme vous même
vous de voir ma famille c'est à dire que
j'aurais bien oui céline petites courses
à faire et j'ai déjà vu tout à l'heure
vous aurez fait alors je n'ai pas besoin
de vous présenter vous n'avez pas trouvé
leur bien nerveux qui sera réussi
non non à ma femme tu vois je ne sais
pas ce qu'est la spad n'est pas à
prendre avec des pincettes
à bientôt mieux presque oui monsieur
c'est une lettre personnelle pour
monsieur pas un commissionnaire bien
apporter pour moi alors que vous
permettez
par exemple quand elle regarde n'est pas
énorme non non non la ferme assurance a
beau bien toi je crois que c'est clair
concernant les femmes sont étonnantes
sadoun de vie n'auriez jamais ce qui
m'arrive coelho gars qui arrive deux
doigts tu n'es pas tant et si bien
bonjour de ré à mes enfants
tenez vous bien je viens le fait qu un
but 1-1 wav ou salon la coupe sa télé je
n'invente rien je suis celle qui ne vous
a pas quitté des yeux l'autre soir au
palais royal voit vous moi vous il
parfaitement où il ne va pas quitter les
yeux fannie mae
merci ouais vous étiez dans une loge
avec votre femme est un monsieur est un
monsieur ben voilà c'est toi t'as rien
monsieur c'est à dire x premier venu
grisaille du ciel à maré brabo d'ide ont
eu peur du lendemain c'est bien mon tour
des gens prennent moi vous en avez c'est
comme ça que j'ai su si vous étiez
depuis ce temps je ne rêve que de vous
non elle ne rêve que de mourir ça mérite
bien ça
et oui il ya ce truc c'est que les
retombées pas bon se lever tous les
rêves sont dans la nature ça doit
dépendre de l'estomac ou aux jambes
normale dans toi non
je suis prête à faire une folie voulez
vous la faire avec moi pour petite elle
tombe bien un final pourquoi ça
maintenant voyons pas ce que je vous dis
je vous attendrai aujourd'hui à 5h à
l'hôtel du minet galant ou illégal
c'est un montre tout scène les bravos on
s'endette une qui la connaît c'est une
pratique hein pourquoi pourquoi est-ce
que cet hôtel bah ouais mon cher tenez
c'est toujours là que je fais mais farce
voyez vous ça puisque c'est que d'être
une pure je l'ignorais beaubois je suis
sûr que tour mais là non on connaît de
nombreuses et tout autant mes amis quoi
elle a pleuré non mais parfaitement
tenir regardez-le alors là je n'invente
rien post scriptum pourquoi en nous
écrivant ne puis-je retenir mes larmes a
fait que ce soit des larmes de joie et
non de désespoir
pauvre petit coeur il n'y a pas à dire
que ce n'est pas ça la halle regarder
elle a inondé au mes enfants quoi aum et
d'enfants mais qu'est ce qu'elles font
danser l'âme qui sont si proches que
propose la larme à son secret la larme à
son mystère
c'est un mélange alors respectons son
secret est même nommé en mai de la
guerre elle alors moi aussi je fais des
meilleurs 1 pendant que nous étions là
où palais royal que nous nous doutions
n'a rien une femme nous dévorer des yeux
voilà tard marie kuhn ça nous faisait de
l'oeil toi non non il m'avait bien plu
va percevoir en nombre je croyais que
c'était à moi pas vraiment comme ça tu
as cru que cet état mais triple idiot
que je suis mais évidemment bah
évidemment moi mais ça n'est pas moi qui
veut taper dans l'oeil c'est toi c'est
moi madame clos mais c'est toi qu'est la
paix pour moi écrit comme on l'a dit mon
nom en désignant ma loge naturellement
comme elle le regardait que toi tu t'es
tu crois mais par bleus mais peut-être
regard de quoi est-ce que je peux
inspirer des payants tandis que toi
c'est tout naturel c'est ta fonction
c'est ça fonctionne
tu as l'habitude de tourner la tête aux
femmes tuées
du nom prénom mail les six mois c'est
pas un mystère
avec ça vous ne le savez pendant la noce
j'ai du charlatan d'accord pas d'accord
il ya des femmes qui se sont suicidés
pour toi à et encore elle va très bien
mais enfin ça n'empêche pas de plus est
très contestable
elle s'est empoisonné dans mangeant des
moules un des beaux louis louis ange
venait de la quitter elle a répandu le
bruit que c'était par chagrin mais la
bordure franchement quand on veut mourir
on approche mesure du moule
c'est beaucoup trop aléatoire alors
alors écoute il n'y a pas d'erreur cette
lettre est à mon nom mais elle est at on
a dream jusqu'ici vous en pensez ou mais
oui mais oui eh bien que plus ce qu'elle
était à mon adresse c'est toi qui as
simenon ainsi qu'ils écoutent ce soir
moi je ne suis pas libre nous en a
manqué le directeur l'america seconde
non non non on peut
tu en meurt dans une taie croire mais
regard de tourner il qu'elle était allée
danser alors dans ce cas j'accepte
encore salma s'est jamais précisément
fait liaison en est ces jours-ci en
prévision d'une aventure la voiture sur
laquelle je compte être harry qui se
trouve momentanément retardé avec qui je
ne peux pas tout
on ne peut pas me dis ouais dans
l'inconnu mais servira d'intérim
mettront peut renaître la série on n'est
pas plus aimable elle est mal à l'aise
là n'ont pas non plus d'ailleurs
pourquoi faire tu n'en as pas besoin du
lac à aller à l'hôtel en question et
demandé la chambre à mon nom moi tu
comprends d'être comme ça je ne reçois
pas su souvent je vous convie ainsi un
jour mes petits-enfants et en admettant
que j'emmène trouve celle ci dans mes
papiers de puisse se dire
fallait-il que grand père fut bon pour
exciter des passions pareil pas je je
serai au moins beau dans la postérité un
ale finale chez les homos sculpté est le
signe assurément deux minutes et je suis
deux minutes un voisin ce sera autre
chose deux minutes
[Musique]
vont-elles du minepia l'enjeu peut bien
l'être encore cette femme qui s'était
prise de moi hôtels du monde single par
coeur je suis là parce qu'on ne le
dérangeait pas si vous le voyez tout à
l'heure vous lui direz que je sors avec
madame du x3 que si je rentre tard il
n'est pas à s'inquiéter
je resterai peut-être à dîner avec une
aiguille d'eau bien je crois que
lui-même ne rentrera pas de bonheur donc
eu alors pour faire ça mais bien parce
qu'il m'a dit je pense qu'il qu'il
banques que si square avec son son
directeur d'amérique
sachez que le savoir eh bien c'est faux
car si demain quelqu'un se moquer j'ai
vu l'habitation la mort ce qu'ils se
trompent
je vais lui dire non non il ne se trompe
pas de jour ne fait pas d'eux est
inutile ça c'est parfaitement
intentionnel
c'est un alibi pour lui permettre de
revenir ce soir en disant qu'il a
confondu la date
je sais parfaitement à quoi bon ton plus
assuré et est parfaitement sain c'est à
moi voyons une à prendre est sans appel
à raconter des histoires il en a deux
vis-à-vis de moi un non pas du tout la
même chose que lors du bal
je comprends votre jeu allait comme vous
savez que maintenant que mon mari me
trompe
vous n'avez plus rien à espérer de moi
alors je croyais et très fort de le
persuader qu'il est le plus fidèle des
défauts surtout par sa saga tant pis ce
sera tout comme un tueur aurait voulu
que dans le monde sait bien que nouvelle
lune à wau allait au sommet distant de
moussa jugeant police
il va céder rooney lui est le bilan
étape web
ouais et avant oui j'ai mis mon cher
comment ça va ouais ouais non le vecteur
la santé quand sa main et liam ya
toujours eu le même émoi émoi mais
justement je m'en allais j'ai pris alors
on va au delà et pour celui qui ira bon
minet galant hors ue et moi mes pouces
il est là et parfaitement avec machin
mais il ya la soupe aux c'est d'ailleurs
elle m'avait dit qu'elle allait
probablement des vents de qu'elle allait
se battre devant
oui enfin aller mais nous attendons
qu'elle allait venir en avance et les
mêmes voulez vous que c'est un premier
trailer elle est totale avec mike bibby
cette matinée le thé à votre compagnie
gérez vous votre dr oui c'est ce qu'il
m'a dit oui il m'a fait oublier comment
ou line et c'est cette faille de type i
hate à l'arrivée mais oui parfaitement
parfaite donc est ce à quoi qui m'a fait
mouliner n'est ce pas il faut bien pour
savoir si vous êtes en état d'être
assurée et que ça les regarde
ce n'est pas ma guillaume assurent le
cema femmes un supporter ça vous ne
m'avez pas dit comment d'une assurance
vous m'avez pas demander pour qui c'est
un petit malheur facilement réparable
vous n'en êtes pas ça prenne pas d'âme
au mesnil-esnard à calais la compagnie
etc etc etc et on lui fera faire qu'on
met à boire
adam ça ne vaut pas un ne vont pas y
aller au panier euro dollar est la règle
il ya la police y est c'est pour n est
pas non non non mais alors le large à ce
n'est pas possible
sympa sous l'ère aulas tout nom fabrique
vous n'êtes pas si jeune
bon ça n'est pas de la jalousie et au
look essayer de ferriol à la dignité nos
projets non ils allouent saïan supa vous
êtes sûr de la fidélité de ronaldo
istanbul d'ailleurs ça ne m'étonne pas
du voyage c'est pas ça y est c'est
qu'elle sait déjà c'est le terrible elle
n'en serait pas à tv voyez vous ces
bibelots et mélanger oui mais enfin vous
savez à
si alain pinson pour monsieur les
messieurs il recevrait une balle dans le
dos qui vient me sentirai temps les uns
à lui et noël
ah oui mais vous supposez que loyer
suppose croyez support non je répète
nous à notre niveau est une charmante
déclaration elle y insufflant les places
ben voyons monsieur oui le second tous
les bons cg autre chose à faire pour
réparer dossier je suis à pas dans un
seul instant qu'elle essaie mais chez
lui c'est ce tour mais tout le monde
mais c'est un ami à moi c'est aussi le
courtier de la compagnie d'un charmant
garçon et monsieur tournai
il est parti qui n'a qu'un défaut
d'ailleurs zem coureurs comme une fille
à vue d'oeil aussi une pressée de partir
c'est parce que il ya une femme qui
l'attend ah oui enfin quand je dis qu'il
attend c'est peut-être moi parce qu'elle
est à moi qu'elle a écrit une lettre
brûlant d'amour et bernard miquel et non
de s'était paré jolie niort l'espace m
ce n'est pas signé quelques anonymes
peut-être joué les gens n'arrivent à le
croire ce doit être une femme du monde
enfin quelques femmes mariées et 20 à
quoi vous vite s'il vous plaît à quoi
vous vite à quoi je vite
oui oui vous avez au style d'abord au
top pour les boycotts sont moins
sentimentale enfin plus positive à l'em
lyon qu'aucun acteur
et ça vous fait rien thomas vous aux
mauvaises herbes à quoi il allait la
faire là quitte à paris pour les non
lieux comment ça il a un chien j'ai
dévié dans son but les langues c'est moi
la banderole et n'ont rien alors madame
ils étaient les flics
écoutez ça n'est sûrement pas votre faim
parce que ces femmes ont la même
écriture aujourd'hui mais il ya la
connaît ce n'est pas moi qui ai la barre
d'espacé c'est pas moi c'est tout même
temps aime quoi elle l'enquêté là tout à
l'heure mais ses premières tournées tout
ça mais je lave pas j'avais dit qu'on
sort la chance rien la preuve
ayez les touristes augmentant la lave
gouvernement après les allées à l'ordre
de la toison bat restons pas dans
l'amitié et la ville
on appuie son ami
et là il était là bonjour madame si les
gens et les mamies matière de fromage
sera pour une autre fois
[Musique]
merial est d'amener nos là il n'est pas
là très bien et l'obligeant si vous le
voyez été de lui dire que j'ai laissé
toutes les pièces sur le bureau il
n'aura qu'à relever le nez les noms
d'oiseaux volent en train d'attendre
plus longtemps allez allez allez allez
allez lyon
ah qu'est-ce qui va desservir dans cette
maison qui laisse aller au revoir google
oui oui moi un voyou mais quoi qu'en
dise le parti cette époque
hier vous autorise à doubler leur antre
les mettent au web aime ça
comment patriat et mathieu lavallée qui
me mokrane la yonhap
il est moins bien en ce moment en quoi
il est parti aux manettes wii et madame
amélie dhesse rodez avec raymond à
l'indien et et on aide hagen est parti
aussi lancé la games voyons voyons
entier à envoyer là-bas pour les
prévenir alors arrivée qui je fais qui
je vais monde ira etienne mais audard
mais à voir autre chose au mas saint
ouen mais l'apport pas enfin nous sommes
sur un volcan un drame épouvantable
c'est un double assassinat peut-être que
yi j'ai le temps avant le banquet de
courir ici que chez tournelle sa droite
en moi toi non ça pour mon chapeau
william hague et qu'il n'avait pas le
temps d'expliquer cependant absents
retour la drôme est ici pour une raison
quelconque tuer des lui surtout qu'il
n'aille pas au rendez-vous qu'il sait il
y va de sa fille ana et tu m'as bien
compris de sa vie oui oui bon c'est à
dire on m avait dit alain launay t il
huawei
aujourd'hui les rôles à miami olivia le
oui c'est moi la pêche comprendre ce que
vous payez jamais on est bleu là on
pourrait aller ou éloigné de mon manège
à nouvelle tournée mais après sur la tue
ton mais après tournelle jamais vu de
près de paris je lui ai dit tout ce que
tu m'avais charge et lui dire il n'a
même pas voulu m'écouter aux îles farm
nouvelle
[Musique]
je te vois
m
non
[Musique]
j'ai dit j'ai dit vous faites c'est ma
chambre
monsieur l'a fait sa une chambre en fait
vous même monsieur alors vous appelez ça
une chambre fait un esprit c'est un fait
mais n'a pas relevé à temps
madame plutôt kwakwa de l'esprit
maintenant parts à 17 ans on me dit tout
de suite vous traduis la maison par un
hôtel borgne au nom mademoiselle vous
serez tct nos maisons de luxe maison
comme il faut oui ne vient que des gens
se marier oui mais pas ensemble ce que
ça vous regarde
ils veulent son code avantage puisqu'ils
le font chacun de leur côté mademoiselle
ça permet de juger m plus honteuse
maintenant tu as lu le livre en fait moi
je lui ai dit c'est celle ci qui
n'affiche pas de secousses rage
empreintes de pas l'avoir eu un peu
souvent régiment il aurait fallu
qu'elles marchent encore ayew telma
franck le marché roi tu dois je pense à
la gaudriole merci donc aux hommes
voir et encore c'est la france est bien
sûr voilà les cinq heures pourquoi n'es
tu pas entendu quand tu devrais en
faveur du travail et oui sinon ouais
alors c'est vrai ça voilà un autre qui
décroît rien qui a la chance d'avoir des
rhumatismes indiscutable pour les quatre
jolis sidérante
mais pourquoi je me le demande parce que
c'est trop de coeur et je ne dois pas
laisser rien ne permet dans la liste
souffle le monsieur n'a qu'une idée se
soustraire à ses devoirs pour aller
courir sous les 10 euros mais bien du
tout en les pistes seront elles à des
boîtes qu'on va fermer en ont d'abord à
l'été public et si on avait eu besoin du
vieux monsieur malades en son absence un
qui l'aurait atteint par ce vieux
monsieur malapa - dia sur sarthe et du
poivre d'arvor 10 mai à la ferme dans sa
chambre juncker s'est dit plus que ça
croyez à personne ne voulait pas nos
moniteurs esf if you please nos paris
comme on me l'a dit c'est parce que la
demande est si personne n'était venu
c'est extraordinaire c'est malik adjout
parlant l'anglais et lui parle pas
français mois après qu elle ait pas
l'autre l'on n'est pas une raison pour
qu'on prenne à sienne a pas d'école peut
se vanter d'avoir le sourire aux pauvres
ta phrase une fois qu'il vient sa flamme
qui l'attendait à poser là on lui
reprocher sa - elle est assise avec les
fans de déco je crois pas que j'allais
faire signer ma chérie c'est toujours
pour me faire une folie ce texte bonjour
dispose de beaux affection profonde de
ces saugrenue voilà une pile de draps
vous la montrer la lingerie ou à un
autre allemand sans moi bien tu métier
bourrique
je pense vous disposez pas des élus
deschamps brise vous rappellerez oui
madame et monsieur qui parle comme ça a
précisé mme en violant sa dépêche
fabien gemini ou un regard très bien et
six passagers ça va bien j'ai plus
besoin de nous bah ya nadal ça
m'étonnait où ce n'est pas ce dont dans
les selles et du couloir save you make
up croisé les gants avec vos petits 2
devant rien nada viable à ce qu'elle dit
la dépêche retenir pour tantôt 5h même
champ deux dernières fois chambry la
chambre de la dernière phase est celle
ci parfait nous allons y jeter leur
deuil mais a fait mieux c'est bien mieux
elle cabinet de palestine et moqueur
regard c'est très important un cabinet
de toilette eau en plus maintenant
pression un peu sur ce bouton pour voir
ce qu'on a décidé donc et toujours à son
poste
ce n'est pas avec moi c'est toi
eh bien tu vas pas qu'ils m'attrapent
tout joueur j'ai suis un an bureau ou
pas mon vieux je te paye pour ça
d'ailleurs un tiroir weapon à la carie
ronge le bois à la carte pour les postes
et des qui n'avait qu'un seul défaut
celui de se saouler que l'on doit la
table mais des casiers sont cadenassées
la partie mais si tu le comme une bombe
il a beau avoir juré qu'il était
corrigée de son riz ce jusqu'en rhône je
les connais mon enrichissement
il a été trois ans mon brasseur
président connu ses repentirs il allait
du lundi au samedi et le dimanche par la
capitale de madère c'était un précurseur
en attendant moi je ne le ferais pas au
bloc jeu franck est une de ces tripoter
qu'ils ont été corrigés jusqu'au samedi
4 dimanche que c'était à recommencer
n'empêche que c'était une paire nos
services honnêtes travailleurs dévoués
schumann bousculer seul bien le malmener
c'était une joie c'est à dire que quand
je me suis ok mon pied quelque part le
roi n'était pas son cousin et tu va si
bien
je battais maintenance fatigue ou lcd
galles voilà un serviteur comme
faisaient les banques que les
domestiques d'aujourd'hui à qui on ne
peut parler que de la bouche en cul de
poule
aussi quand ya quinze jours j'ai trouvé
100 places n'ai pas hésité à demander
d'observer
évidemment cette dépêche
guti les animaux la page la fidh me
regarder comme ça abc a encore des
chances d'y retenir bonne chambre pour
moi et si témoin x et y introduire qui
l'a demandera un monde non bon vous avez
entendu vous aussi en donnant la chambre
ont réservé à monsieur showbiz vous
apprendrez à celle ci puisse y est
maintenant pour disposer n'a pas entendu
espèce de taza qui allaient où il est
allé plus vite que c'était une bonne
nouvelle école nobody's here in time
masques et ni polychromie nos brigitte
buhmann ce matin et la nuit
une façon de sortir vainqueur d'une
boîte impossibilité de couleurs aux
joues reconnaît bonjour la ferraille ont
raison le 16 octobre à une chambre aura
toujours pour vous mais c'est le dr
on est parti me demandez pas encore chez
le docteur ou mieux en étant vite en
vieux monsieur le docteur est en bonne
fortune bonne fortune je suis ont de
petits collages à tous venez vous avez
plus tôt ce mois ci j'ai un peu
papillonner à droite et à gauche à reims
et malsain de ne pas être filmés avec la
mène avec la même nom mais je ne parle
pas de la terre
je parle pour nous avons fait non parce
que si on veut être fidèle en amour nous
n'aurions plus qu'à fermer la baisse
beaucoup paraît judicieux des toits on
entre comme dans un droit dans votre
hôtel je n'ai pas vu notre garçon aux
bureaux proches qu approche non gabriel
le beau gabriel
c'est vrai vous ne savez pas évidemment
de plus tôt non nous n'avons projet dit
gabriel au pourquoi bellucci décoratifs
injuste qu il était trop gentil garçon
il faisait des bégaiements la cliente et
oui vous comprenez que c'était qu'il
accepte un chien client ne peut plus
nier sa maîtresse sans risque est seul à
avoir soulevé par le personnel trou
woods nous sommes d'une maison pour
ouvrir rapidement si vous êtes mais
aussi il faut de la discipline
moi je le connais que ça c'est que
j'étais militaire dans quelques mois oui
là alors c'est donc vrai votre grade
quand la même corde aussi tiens je suis
ancien sergent major ont fait de gamme
de ligne et c'est pour ça qu'on
m'appelle colloque
oui vous êtes colonel le au civil avait
observé dans la vitrine d'un gramme de
plus beaux looks veut tout voir mon sous
le numéro 10 ont besoin d'hommes comme
entamant le centre là n'est pas libre
non hélas aux mélodies c'est la même
disposition
juste au dessus font 20 pour le disent
c'est ça ma main sur yves voilà une
femme précieuse à la dame ferrari si
c'est drôle je me suis souvent demandé
où je l' ai vu un message ne vit pas
connu autrefois une demi-mondaine label
castagna qu'on avait surnommé culotte de
peau castagna castagne attendaient dont
6 is it qui a été si longtemps la
maîtresse du duc de gennevilliers
celle qui s'est fait servir un jour aux
françaises tout nu sur un plat d'argent
voilà vous y êtes là c'est peut-être ma
femme de l'est par elle a eu avec un
pour moi lorsque j'étais sergent 29e
deuxième jeu tu es bon gars me choque
pas et d'argent à pékin pour les
militaires du lot de peau et elle a
voulu marquer
non mais également par ce mal d'autre
part elle avait de l'argent de côté
physique de la réputation enfin je peux
le dire c'était sympa alors je vais
proposer le mariage et puis ça s'est
fait comme ça chez moi mes compliments
mais avant que poser des conditions
j'ai mes principes je lui dis à partir
de maintenant plus de l'ours plus
d'amants parce que je ne sais pas si
vous êtes comme moi mais je trouve que
du moment que vous prenez une femme ne
faut plus qu elle est d'abord vous est
absolument dans le break je tiens avant
tout à la respectabilité
alors voilà on a ouvert cette maison
vous êtes sage il en vit modestement
comme des bourgeois rangée on n'est pas
mal vu dans les deux jours il même à ce
propos j'ai réfléchi à ce que vous
m'aidiez de proposer d'autres jours pour
l'assurance sur la ville mais ben oui ce
projet à 44 ans ma femme
52e avant de reprendre un bon mais c'est
très bien ça on dit toujours qu'il faut
qu'il ya sept ou huit ans d'écart entre
les époux et enfin il vaudrait peut-être
mieux je ne vous dis pas mais enfin
quand on ne peut pas faire autrement il
vaut mieux que ce soit le mari
évidemment évidemment alors si je
pouvais la faire assurer la pauvre
chérie de façon qu'à sa mort là elle y
avait cinquante deux ans ce sera et vous
ça coûterait moins cher
moi si vous voulez pourvu qu'à sa mort
ni à l'autre non non dans ce cas là
c'est à la vôtre
dans la salle un tirage plus du tout on
va écouter nous verrons à trouver une
combinaison mais toujours nombreux à
temps mais vous trouvez tous les matins
de 10 annonce dans le bureau du
directeur de la poste and light company
95 boulevard malesherbes et jeu des cas
demandé le directeur de la compagnie je
ne préviendrai merci de recommencer
c'est bon là vous nobody colle comme ça
par exemple nouvelle école labarde quoi
huawei la barbe un oui languit je me
regarde avec des yeux ronds
je profite de ton ignorance de notre
langue pour te dire ce que je pense
la ola baby baby
la championship au ne manque pas de
toupet
il est entendu personne demandé la
chambre seule madame je ne me trompe pas
c'est bien la dame qui est déjà vu ce
matin on attend que je suis flatté je
comptais bien que ma discrétion
n'assurerait le cas échéant la clientèle
de madame mais vrai je n'attendais pas
sites est monsieur balader façon je ne
vous permets pas de support unique jadad
jeu que j'ai pas matin si madame veut
bien se donner la peine voici la chanson
d'amour elle est très confortable
le lycée bien monsieur je n'en ai que
faire c'est une vicieuse le cabinet de
toilette rochot de froid baddou bonjour
je n'ai pas à l'intention des victoires
très important signalé en cas de
flagrant délit j'appelle de la torture
de matane de chaque côté du lit où il
passait bien je me suis vraiment même
année
[Musique]
au revoir monsieur roy sait qu'une
briderait sa lettre cet homme et d'un
manque de ta peau et chef c'est bientôt
fini tout ramassage de bois est encore
incertain de manchette bon alors vous
ferait plaisir de passe et a livré au
lieu de la laisser traîner ici c'est pas
sa place c'est l'heure où les clients
arrivent mais tu dois être en tenue
beige chef la mentionne célèbre en ce
qu'il veut oui celle de monsieur si je
me trompe ou n'est ce pas monsieur bise
non mais ça leur jeu le jeu ne
représentent d'ailleurs la dpj d'en
produire il a demandé à son nom la dame
est là et bien monsieur désire avoir mon
ami marc il me semble que tu sais que je
ne le connais pas alors avant de
m'engager l'esprit c'est peut-être une
vieille toupie un non rassurez-vous noël
ne va pas avoir le caractère ensuite
remises et les jeunes oui bon bah comme
ses propres le caractère qu'on y va mais
si poitiers me demande un nobody écoles
ce progiciel - ne boutique qu'une
optique devrait servir à beyrouth et à
lanta
je me suis romana mais la madame il a
très bien fait grand bien vous fasse
et et merci c'est gentil ici c'est chez
ses copains c'est bien meublé et sa
dette ça attention ici au nom on peut
faire un carton rien c'est pas tout ça
mais comment se présenter d'une façon
originale
je les retiens comme ça ce sera drôle
avoue t-il coucou coucou au pouce
c'est vous si tout n'est pas si je
m'attendais à l'agréable surprise
économique qu'est ce que vous faites ici
qu'importe ce que j'ai fais une intrigue
voilà une intrigue d'amour c'est être
une suite était une femme une femme kim
est belle elle m'avait joué au théâtre
notamment le coup de foudre elle m'a
écrit et par bonté dans des mois loin du
tout mais pas du tout c'est à cette fin
que je m'en moque je ne la connais pas
je ne veux pas tandis que mon rêve mon
rêve se réalise est là devant moi tout
ça moi voyez bien que c'est moi c'est
pas ça vous qu'on a écrit c'est à mon
mari monsters ressemble à ça ils ne
l'aiment pas diffuser ces mois nous
étions ensemble n'est pas la personne ne
met pas du tout cette lettre à mon mari
c'est de moi de vous entièrement comment
vous écrivait des lettres d'amour à
votre mari je voulais voir s'il me
trompais s'il viendrait de rendez-vous à
et bien vous voyez il faut qu'ils ne
voulaient plus être amoureux parce que
vous pensez que votre mari vous êtes un
fidèle
bien qu'ils n'aient pas et c'est moi
c'est moi qui la verrait bien sa place
comme plus conforme à la vraie 126 et
savez vous ce qu'il a dit en recevant
cette lettre votre lettre non mais dis
mais qu'est ce qu'elle veut cette dame
elle ne céderont pas que je ne trompe
pas ma femme qu'elle a dit ça à courte
portée maintenant devoir tout et vous
reconnaissez à présent nous nous et
comment les plus proches de la
criminelle n'avait plus besoin de ne pas
le tromper ont fièrement lancé mal à moi
de l'avoir soupçonné brad smith et
mazoutant je vous en demande pas mal non
pas de pardon a laissé là moi ça suffira
oui oui oui c'est le chat timor et le
monde je t'aime je t'aime je vous
attends mort est bon très mode je
croyais que c'était mon mari qui faisait
couper les affaires bien on frappe on
lui répond jean marie madeleine
mais qu'est ce qui vous prend et c'est
moi de remettre de vos émotions
mélangées au contraire profiter de votre
trouble donc il échoue on évalue dans
ces moments là les sensations s'enfuira
plaisantant à aulas il venait et pour
qu'ils me prenez-vous comment mais
n'avez-vous pas laissé entendre tout à
l'heure que que ont consenti à être à
votre amant thouy couché avec vous le
prenez vous pour une prostituée
et alors quoi mais le fleuve les
émotions qu'ils comportent parler les
yeux dans les yeux
la main dans la main je vous donne la
meilleure partie de ma mère d'accueil
matt est ok au
ça quelle pensée alloudi d'élaborer la
salle entonne tic ont fait l'amour d'une
femme nommée pour entendre tous nous
plus bas vers le haut ce que les
événements se met de la partie
quand votre mari lui même j'attends vos
draps castrés votre bariba dame qui m'a
envoyé non madame votre mari et c'est le
seul que viendra la résistance non non
non non mais pas en ont tourné le
meilleur cahier que je me contenterai se
reposer le flirt a eu les yeux dans les
yeux la main dans la main c'est la
moitié de votre personne j'ai moins en
rapport avec les circonstances et moi
qu'est ce que vous voulez que je fasse
notre enquête et de votre coeur à y
songer à lui les avantages que vous me
ferait une perspective d'énervement dans
le vide
je te désire j'avais satisfont indiqué
pour toute faveur pour la fois encore
faire les courses de voile a
probablement qu il comptait son petit
stand pas quand il en a envie de se
promener un organisme non non non non
non vous avez ainsi l'ignorance des
règles fondamentales des choses de
l'amour
moi je vous les ancêtres il ne pensait
pas que la situation résume ridicule
lorsque devant mes yeux en sortant d'ici
gros jean comme devant
vous êtes un mois
[Applaudissements]
si tu la tiens elle est à moi à redmond
wa avant de marc aymon mary mead pixma
aux caisses à mary powell mathis jette
quelques bouts peut-être que vous faites
là d'où sortez-vous pas par wordpress et
raymonde elle va répondre à la demande
totale
non personne remo oui
ouais italienne l'antitrust ouais je
suis amené la bbc et je trouve pas levé
en mode bourrier aussi j'ai pu foot qui
avait été partagée d'un milliard à
baptiste et à batista ouais c'est à toi
et baptiste meyer dieu bakhit a fait du
vermont mais non madame je la revois sur
la revoir bon tiens tiens
la personne au monde kama lameca
d'émotion mais mon avis mais oui ben ari
qui disent que c'est quoi ce but très
bonne vue déguisée en domestique comment
pourquoi je ne sais pas pour nous passer
csu mais qu'est ce que c'est celui là où
ça là je ne sais pas c'est vrai c'est un
malade il a surgi comme ça là tout à
coup qu'est ce que vous faites là vous
baisez blogging va venir
c'est le comble à introduire des
spectateurs n'ont donc jamais chaque
partie mon ami fait que le parti il est
absolument absolument aller fichiers
volcan non mais si susan vous n'avez
qu'à appuyer sur le bouton là je
retournerai là de suite la ville assure
aller ça va pas très bien
et bah quoi doral cindy je suppose que
tu vois mon temps les apparences tout
d'accord mais je te jure que nous ne
sommes pas qu'au paradis la vérité une
pension ni l'un ni l'autre à nous
rencontrent tout ça c'est la faute de la
lettre la lettre oui c'est moi moi qui
suis cause de tout je l'avais fait
écrire parce que c'est l'exact demande
pardon je croyais qu'ils me trompais way
or dis moi que tu me crois que tu ne
veux pas de ma parole mais oui mais oui
je te crois mes décisions rue alors
mourir quand je vois je vois tu ne me
crois pas c'est pourtant l'évidence même
mais comment tu qu'on va écouter siège
vous demande pardon mais ces projets il
portait le vermouth au 4 août et manuel
qu'est-ce que tu là mouais on a besoin
d'instances grave nous parler de faire
mouche et il faut bien le katla temps et
n'est là la bouteille moi c'est assez de
cette comédie tiens un jury mois
boussekine mois bas s'il le faut j'aime
mieux tous que ce calme effrayant allez
pas moi aussi or et celle là par exemple
d'ailleurs mes essais je vous assure ma
belle tu vois tu ne me tutoie plus qui
s'amortit moi tout de lui tu sais moi
moi moi je veux bien mais c'était sûr
mais d'un bon repas matin moyen de leurs
deux par les belges appellent la
raymondie n'avons mais jetaient sur la
mort d'un petit bois dis moi tu me
croire mais oui j'ai des cornes en
novembre à 6 mois vous embrasse moi -
embrasse plus correctement veut toujours
on aime moins aimé mais c'est moi je
veux bien
à lui pas passer ça donne merci pour moi
aussi embrasse-moi a lui aussi livré
pour le prouver que tout pas de moi non
plus pas bon on a un chien qu'il est
grand et enfin un peu de change
oui la dame surtout elle la donne on va
maintenant il faudrait y porter vers new
look est mort ça veut dire que c'était
très gentil et tu mon mari nous
ouais non mais si le garçon de l'hôtel
coin avant qu ils en rêvaient la
transporte aussi brouillon mais tout ça
est cédé à quiproquos d'abord moi je
m'appelle poche parce que si vous ne
croyez pas demandez plutôt à batista
baptistin baptiste un vieux monsieur
made you were here baptiste m
oui j'ai pas de cesse d'y voir un peu
tiqué je suis le vainqueur
c'est donc pas bon voici mais c'est pour
moneyweek il ya monsieur ses plages la
poche
le garçon de l'aude l icac j'ai dit ça
voyons comment il serait vrai une
ressemblance paris voyons c'est pas
possible ça c'est un coup monté
oui chef sa guitare je vous demande
pardon mais chez platon sa femme et ses
fils à d'autres je voyais je vous prie
midi et bauchi si il me binet ya main
mais je trouverais là pour commencer
c'est pour incarner je l'apprécié
certains garçons une espèce est
alcoolique
le garçon c'était le garçon d'hôtel
vraiment nous allons embrasser un garçon
d'hôtel je sais bien qu'elle ne dit pas
je n'ai pas entendu moi je suis tout
abasourdi une poigne une ressemblance
pareil ça n'est pas possible
pourtant il faut bien se rendre à
l'évidence assistant départ le patron le
traité comme il a traité je douterais
encore mais du coup depuis quelque part
non même pour me donner le change
victor emmanuel n'irai pas jusqu'à
accepter des coups de pied dans le but
d'arriver il était temps
mon ami que d'émotions j'ai la gorge
sèche de l'eau donnez moi un peu de
l'eau
oh vous activement dans lequel il est
bel et bon ça croyez vous c'était le
garçon d'hôtel ya des choses dans la vie
alors sait-on c'est bien oui c'est dur
mais témoin dans des bus s'ils tombent
merci macgé la veille et si la foule est
dur et qu'on va donc d'y arriver son
grand ami on a du lourd c'est à dire une
chose quand c'est à vous demander
monsieur c'est que je picore emmanuel
mekhissi dont toujours puis adapté
victor-emmanuel qu'elle va mieux oui je
ne sais pas
toutes ces émotions je me sens faible
faible comme si j'allais me trouvais ma
non non non je préfère ça à mon ami
c'est pas pour moi évidemment si vous
croyez que c'est pour bientôt dit vous
devriez vous attendre un peu pour
procéder à l'achat sur le lit de laval
sapristi mais vous serez toujours un bon
mais elle oublie même partie mon ami je
vais partir vous n'allez pas dit s'ils
n'ont qu'à les coûts de maintenance et
le leak a tourné c'est pas lui dit pas
débat lancé par trois syndicats snu
mais les rênes monde ici mais qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça mais simon reconnu
je suis jolie et en toile est non
salariés en tout cas un way you lie et
ouais ouais ouais ouais
batman incarné bien les biens megaton
personnes mortes et d'hôtels voilà
quelqu'un quelqu'un une maison
centenaire fenêtre l'argenterie on sait
boudier monsieur de mademoiselle d'abord
voici un objet d'art dont je ne
m'explique pas bien l'usagé que je viens
de trouver la terre tiens c'est trop je
viens bijoux anciens vieux idiote il a
redit et poserait au mur c'est ça c'est
ça qui les lie au 10 - mademoiselle
il n'est pas venu une dame demandé à
chambrer gentiment mais monsieur diali
faut que je revoie son arrivée surgir
d'un moment à l'autre
c'est pour eux qu'il a duré plusieurs
seulement j'avais lorsque monsieur tenu
ses entraînements merci mais non merci
mais nous nous parlons des cieux
[Applaudissements]
mais hélas pas c'est renforce et moi
copé tornare et c'est moi qui reçoit
l'écossé vous n'aviez que vous étiez
mari non mais ce que vous vous imaginez
une seule semaine
non moi cornavin pas les deux chambres
et attend un petit monsieur
ouais monsieur monsieur kalt crochet
évidemment mais c'est un crochet mais
pourquoi prendre ce monsieur je sais
qu'aucune monsieur salon bon goût et
monsieur langue en anglais lcc n'a pas
d'école j'ai pas les rumeurs en disant
non et puisque monsieur larry ce que
monsieur n'a plus besoin de moi je sais
pas te permettre n'est ce pas je veux
courir après la peau qui l'a attrapé
alors monsieur monsieur permet de se
parler payer mon vieux fusil merci j'ai
pas si est dans l'air aujourd'hui mais
alors ils me font l'effet d'avoir un ton
dans le coco est envoyée c'est pour
fouiller bella bella
appartement fasel des français donc qui
vient parce que devront verser dans
l'escalier quand il courait c'est bien
dans les chambres des métiers chantepie
à ceux qui a pas si madame il m'a
demandé vendredi à ce nom là tout ce que
je sais c'est que c'est une histoire à
n'y rien comprendre
il est venu pour prévenir une dame
qu'elle est à déguerpir parce que son
arrivée est au courant de tout et quand
ils se trouvaient face à face avec la
belle plante il s'est trouvé c'était sa
femme à lui c'est un vrai les bus un
saint mais qu'est ce que vous me
racontez vous avez l'air de faire une
salade incarne madame je vous dise que
j'étais bon c'est bien dit michael est
elle la chambre au nom de monsieur
chance by la chambre c'est celle là
madame bon alors j'y vais à 20 13
moi on m'a dit que la chambre à la
disposition de quillan en moi à des bus
a des bureaux au web
prénom de ma vie je passe mon mari entre
5 heures et 5 heures 18 à 5h30 tout sera
fini parce qu'elle n'aurait pas attendu
renvoyons par la page où vous l'avez lu
étienne vallée d'aure quoi mais parce
que je pouvais les pêcheurs ne pouvant
dire moi même je fais un bon acabit mes
bras je me suis aperçu qu'il n'était que
de mains ok alors j'ai couru et j'ai
couru pour vous dire mais quoi ton
manière fort malheureuse enfant mais
quelle folie michael faulds nous mêmes
mais non le voile aura le grand jeu
c'est tout moi aussi pourquoi ne pas
savoir signer votre relève la lettre qu
ils l'être mais celle qu'on m'avait
écrit pour me donner rendez-vous ici
mais qu'est ce qui vous fait supposer
que ce soit moi qui a parce que voilà
moi ne sachant pas n'est ce pas je
démontre à votre mariage ça il a reconnu
votre week-end ça vous dit
il est capable vous tuer restait aux
lettres cette fille
[Applaudissements]
non mais vous la rampe la caisse qu'ils
ont toujours été là c'était ce que vous
aimez les toits de l'école et la famille
respire décès violent il ya du
brouillard
non mais dites aux poches encore qu'est
ce que vous dites
animal social et monsieur quand j'écris
mais monsieur jean paul walsh est mais
je suis monsieur showbiz
je me suis sentie baisser tête hors de
l'eau ce temps mike comrie voilà les
sous il est complètement sous monsieur
vous recevrez mes témoins ah oui est
absurde et même un soutien pour shanghai
et des chrétiens a retiré cette
plaisanterie et samedi c'est un fou il
est fou mon dieu mon dieu
cette annonce ne va pas de même c'est
pas comme ça et maintenant quant à
jonathan m'a plu
venu pour relater leur effet la route
est encore vide renoir pas bleu et dire
que quand on m'a abandonné ce quick est
fondu de cet ivrogne
qu'est-ce qu'il ya quoi question
pourquoi est ce que nous barxell la
tenait monteiro disparaître dr finch il
faut disposer d'un moment pour faire ma
femme en une minute trente unités en une
seconde
ou que le rasoir eh bien quoi dans ma
chérie ça ne va donc pas pu m'être dit à
lagord et j'y suis resté c'est ma force
et ma veste et esthète d'amour que l'on
va laisser mon pote plus haut depuis la
mort bien placide a laissé un chapeau
wave baquet du mail dans lequel il bat
tim jack est pas mauvais et plâtre mais
comme il faut jaya d'abord un airplay un
penneteau sans voix un autre et non dit
moi je demanderais sida comme ceux qui
meurent ont rendu moyens alors bon cap
chelle encore bébé pour soigner les
malades
quoi qu'est ce que la troisième
mais à part qu'il devenait une route une
seconde mais vite aux médias ou par les
français il est soumis sa lancée des
risques et c'est pour ça nous dérange et
nous n'avez qu'à prendre un siphon et à
la rose et s'était calmée cette affaire
a pris la tête devenir de monsieur jean
pierre laval ce pas évidemment puisque
jusqu'ici le seul buteur tahitien
le le fou est parti il est parti oh là
là là là bas qu'est ce que j'ai pris eh
bien si c'est comme ça qu'il reçoit sa
clientèle qu'elle énerve du même mon
dieu on doit par ailleurs deux fois ma
langue mon chapeau à marrakech qu'il
avait posé là qu'est ce qu'ils sont
devenus les donateurs à huy le garçon
[Musique]
n'est pas aussi
ces scandales des watts appelé lundi à
la halle 6 mois le désert 1/3 de
philippe et la pente
il est des caténaires ont été attentifs
on rit on arrive à être reparti il ne
quittait pas de m'abandonner pas mon
mari tu as vite vous allez dans le vert
tout le monde
mon dieu un homme qui était pas le petit
est favorite et missionnaire des filles
adorent personnes dans cet hôtel moi
dans la chambre de mes chers amis
politiques sceptiques les golfeurs âgés
à douchez salariaux qui vous entourent
poursuivre un homme tue et surtout les
verts attend dé moi mais que c'est vrai
quoi c'est par ici la sortie
c'est dans la crise tiens toi ma femme
voilée ma famille dont lé mal évolué
première oui et moi et là tout ce qui
brille et fait mouche sur 7 et 6
[Musique]
c'est tout
oh
[Musique]
oh mon dieu etienne et tient en général
quand olalalala l'art quand on était mis
en avant sport made who will tell encore
fourré retrouver antoine est antoinette
mais toi qui comme ça respecte mans
qu'est ce que ça veut dire deux temps
permet moi de te demandes pourquoi
mettez en termes et tu peux en faire
j'ai à bâle par exemple tiens si tu sais
plus ouvrir une porte maintenant bien
celle là elle est forte mais il faut
savoir l'importance venu me dire un peu
ce que tu fabriques et à l'heure à
l'hôtel du minet calandre ou quoi à
l'hôtel du nil également qu'est ce que
c'est que ça enfin plutôt joli addition
prendre une demi heure aux animations
oui toi bouger d'ici et ce que nous dira
je dis la vérité il n'a pas bougé d'ici
un loncin certes je m'attendais à tous
que tu trouverais une bonne raison
d'explications ingénieuse mais me
répondre que tu n'as pas été à l'hôtel
du annonce un film est pourtant pas de
dire ce qu'ils n'aiment pas mais
malheureuse je t'ai vu de mes propres
yeux une et après qu'est ce que ça
prouve que tu n'aies vide
oui non étaples alors que j'étais
surprise la remontée des amitiés dans
les gradins anglais tombé sur moi
toutefois
voilà une raison comme si on ne se
comprenait pas dans toutes les langues
pour certaines choses qu'un vote leur
pantomime tu n'étais pas dans les bras
de l'anglais sipa vous êtes ici et non
de aux femmes au helmand comme une femme
du monde à tout n'a pas bougé d'ici
eh bien c'est ce que nous allons savoir
qu'est ce que tu vas faire interroger le
concierge s'il me dire ah oui si tu es
surpris
l'accord contient deux véhicules du
cumul mais pas celle là
le temps que tout le monde se moque de
toi il croyait qu'ils allaient voir
rouler mais maintenant tu sens que tu
vas être obligé alors annoncé vous
monsieur lombard bon goût à la question
va peut-être vous étonner mais j'ai
besoin de savoir
voyons à telle heure ma femme est elle
sortie aujourd'hui comment elle n'est
pas sortie
mais oui non mais c'est pas possible dit
vous n'avez pas dépasser comment elle
est venue manger la soupe avec vous oui
oui oui mais je comprends quand personne
ne dit rien ou alors il est venu pour
moi non voyons voyons voyons voyons
voyons voyons voyons scène français un
truc c'est un vrai sens large qui
comprend rien et c'est bien c'est bien
c'est bien je vous remercie
je vous demande pardon monsieur fiche la
paix - c'est à se demander si je suis
sujet la rue parce qu'on peut être bête
canton des échéances c'est bon c'est bon
aller à la cuisine
reprendront cette explication la voilà
voilà
chaque femme d'un grand cynisme ou bien
alors il faut que je me fasse soigner
voilà à quoi bon madame ses biens les
plus précieux que je ferai j'espère que
maintenant vous êtes suivi pour les spas
moi ici je ne sais pas dans quelles
dispositions encore à montmagny vous
avez vu tout à l'heure nous a rencontré
la seconde fois à l'hôtel de mignano il
avait l'air de vouloir vous s'étrangler
vous comprenez que si jamais la faute
disent ils eurent pr neige
oui khazen quant à air force one pour
asseoir le chabrot vous avez n'ont pas
tous les mêmes ondes à ce que dans
l'entreprise
et voilà comment dont les responsables
auront d'abord quoi les responsabilités
après tout il s'est rien passé c'est pas
votre faute si ne s'est rien passé
tous les cas mon mari n'en sais rien
s'il ne s'est rien passé et nous
trouvons là bas il n'a le droit de se
figurer ce qui te sa figure d'ailleurs
sa colère de temps à prendre évidemment
pas ce que je ne comprends pas par
exemple c'est pourquoi cette colère
s'est manifestée site arrive car enfin
quand il a surgi la première fois devant
du mois assis sur son libre arbitre à la
main là il n'a pas paru autrement
estomaqué de nova dont il avait plein le
plutôt content si on peut dire comment
il nous a même embrassé le bon et flan
montreront plus tard en vivres et ils
brandissent pour 2000 par est indigne et
pourtant dans ce genre d'aventuré sont
généralement il a fait un constat dont
on s'aperçoit du premier coup ce ne sont
pas des choses qui donnent à la
répétition et c'est ce qu'on m'a dit
c'est
comme on dit on a sonné c'est peut-être
lui vraiment aucun grave elle tragique
du tournoi mais j'en ai ils font comme
ça hop je ne veux pas rentrer chez moi
un de nos jours mais j'ai tourné du
monde par ailleurs je la revends
s'agirait inviter n'importe où sous les
ponts et de retrouver de nouveau face à
face avec l'enfance de marisa jamais
jamais j'ai eu trop peur parlons-en de
ton mari quel énergumène quand ils nous
avaient soumis légale en tournée moi
j'ai fait ce qui lui a pris il s'est mis
à nous poursuit en 3d sans la bonne mère
comme c'est l'habitude et oui nous
sommes un peu pourquoi comment vous
aussi vous avez subi sa chasse à courre
du madame que le volcan nous avons
quelques sous pour lui à moi je ne suis
pas remise salle heureusement j'ai
trouvé ton mari qui m'a soutenu et
entraîné son s'ajouter failli gâcher
parce qu'il souhaite arriver c'est mon
mari qui est oui même bien effrayer lui
aussi je sais pas si c'est l'émotion qui
brusquement lui a tapé sur le cerveau
toi aussi tu as remarqué mon si j'ai
remarqué mais j'avais vu dix minutes à
fond vous n'avez parlé très raisonnable
on m'avait averti des dispositions mon
mari et supplier nement là les taac
survient la selle poursuite amérique on
dégringole l'escalier tous deux on se
retrouve au bas et ils me regardent
drôlement étoiles tant il me dit ah la
la qu'est ce que c'est que ce pour rouge
vous connaissez vous dans ma tête quand
nancy je le connais mais évidemment
puisque c'est mon mari vous le
connaissez aussi bien que moi peut il me
répond mais je ne vous connais pas qui
êtes vous en fait je bats toi papa john
douglas shand disent qu'ils déménagent
en jeu le fixe il brillait pas par
nature il se met à l'eau débiter un tas
de choses incohérentes
voilà comme un ouvrage coach sait que
c'était le garçon d'hôtel
montée du bois qu'on lui avait pris sa
livrée en résine et fils est un sens à
sens et là dessus qu'est ce qui lui
passe par la tête de vouloir montrer
l'échelle marchande 20 mois alors je
bondis jeudi voyons voyons chambi jean
peas
il me fait proche alors le trac me prend
je plante là ton mari et son marchand de
vin et je me mets à filer of a filetta
toujours filantes ne comprends pas je ne
comprends pas tout noir il a perdu la
tête pouces est un coup monté une
conférence s'est également voir le jour
n'est pas c'est tout je croyais que vous
alliez non nous sommes dans un jeu entre
maris qui veut brûler la cervelle rien
qui est en train de perdre la sienne ça
ce n'est pas de chance mais ça ça
m'étonnerait la face au cs sse a sauvé
quelques fois c'est vrai comme en fait
foi cette affaire
c'est pourtant si on a salué cette ces
capteurs évidemment ce matin c'est
monsieur à eybens mais je ne sais pas ce
que monsieur je suis ouvert il est entré
comme ça et il m'a dit est ce que ses
disciples demeure monsieur showbiz
oui l'état oui monsieur moi j'ai cru
d'abord qu'ils voulaient vivre
alors pour être à la hauteur j'ai fait
pour sûr que c'est ici que de leur
nation en guise mais il rigolait pas il
a rapproché et il m'a dit vous voulez
vous le prévenir que je viens au sujet
d'un livre est bon oui métal oui
monsieur
non non ça va pas recommencer cette
comédie danse oui monsieur dans
l'antichambre il attend peur comme on
l'attend dans l'antichambre par exemple
qu'est ce que tu fais la jop fougueuse
que c'est ta place dans l'antichambre
comme un fournisseur d'un modem - ch
nous voyons des signes est un monsieur
showbiz même toit ni à la dame adamantin
op je vous reconnais vous ces voûtes été
tantôt à l'hôtel du minet galant oui
monsieur oui c'est vous le cul
monsieur madame ou six ans passés c'est
la petite taille de l'hôtel avait dit qu
on s'est embrassés à whistler
et puis son gigolo robin celle là par
exemple via pourvoyant victor hedman ans
victor emmanuel moche d'abord à la poche
pas envie mais la petite dame aussi
c'est madame avec qui conte la d'étaler
la cause du pont rouge
on va déployer vous dites résultats
ternes est un voleur mais dit alors
c'est tout le monde demeure ensemble
qu'est-ce que vous avez sont gentils
méchants un peu loufoque dans la famille
mais qu'est ce qui l'a le malheureux je
rassure tu traînes montré un excellent
ne peut pas tout téléphone monsieur le
docteur est ce que vous voudrez du matin
et guide vous partez monsieur lambert et
oubliez pas d amitié jambe tandis que
wii fit illusion comme ça c'est pas
possible que nous n'étions pas un coup
monté c'est facile oui j'avais j'avais
accroché mali voillot et puis alors et
par un nombre assez si tu es malade ils
vont te soignes mais si au contraire
c'est une attitude qu'on du projet de
déclarer l'esprit compte a expliqué
comment les choses se sont passées ont
approuvé par l'usp et qu'il n'y avait
jamais rien eu entre monsieur tournée
elle et moi on a la mauvaise idée c'est
là pour confirmer la vérité
ça doit suffire maintenant si du
persiste à croire que je ne crois pas
pas du tout l'attitude que comporte la
situation et celle de te donner en
spectacle dans l'idiot ouais mais c'est
pas tant que tu te rend à l'évidence tu
nous embrasse une serre dans ses bras
dix minutes après du saute à la gorge je
me suis retourné et j'ai sauté à la
gorge
ouais mais enfin quoi à quoi ça arrive
ça nous croient que oui ou non pas comme
des ballons en bresse notre bonne foi et
que ça soit fini au vert mais plutôt d'y
fric mais tu as tu peux les 30 mg ont
fait sauter des squats
bon là vous voyez bidon tu pourquoi tu
vois toi maintenant au coin du bois
bob lamonte roquettes mesure où une
mystérieuse à distribuer histoire de se
remettre les sorbiers des vous en auriez
fait au temps où les grils est
complètement grillé le pan du doubs mais
ses parents ont pu vous savez un petit
chalet cuver l'alcool est proche bon si
tu peux
les acheteurs de cheveux longs mais si
elle retient puis si tu es trop diluée
moi je vois plutôt reconnaît justement
était en train de téléphoner janvier oui
sachant qu'ils entraîneront qu'est ce
qu'il ya là bien que monsieur qui ne
prend pas
alors si vous êtes gré vous moi en
monsieur webb voirie mais qu'est ce
qu'on vous a fait avaler pour remettre
dans un état pas les gars on chez vous
aussi on médite tomber mon beau navet
pourquoi on doit méditer avec philippe
bachet la paix c'est vrai et je suis pas
plus que vous vous servez la voiture de
mon style frêchien non messi à qui se
perd à ma tête depuis mon arrivée lille
vous croisez pas vrai qu'est ce que vous
voulez à masisi pour bastien champix et
ben je peux voir un épicier
éclair de lucidité pieds pour ne plus
revenir c'est comme ça depuis cette
famille joe hill mais bien et puis
histoire et ben quoi comme quand je me
regarderai teint ouais je suis beau
gâteau mais j'aime donc thème un seul
mais à mon avis oui mais je croyais
voyez-vous acoyer bruit au je ne reviens
pas mais est-ce qu'il vous est déjà
arrivé à votre connaissance jamais
respecté jamais été que ces phénomènes
d'accumulation
c'était à la musique musée jusqu'à la
notion de l'a2 algues vertes de sa
propre personnalité je n'ai jamais
constaté 5g des alcoolique invétéré
après le liberia ils ne m'ont jamais eu
un petit verre au fait ça transforme en
freinant et cela maintient oui quand
même si moi qui la voient contraints
d'aller s'y perd donc c'est vraiment un
petit verre parfaitement ici mais si
mais si quelques fois ça suffit
la liste n'est pas une question de
quantité c'est une question d' idiots 5
raziq voilà l'idiosyncrasie de ce mal ne
savent pas c'est à dire la disposition
de tout un groupe d'individus à venir
l'idiot à on veut nous venons venons
enfin parce qu'on vienne venant des
l'idiosyncrasie c'est à dire la façon
propre à chaque individu de ressentir
l'effet du choc
ainsi un pic de trois sites par jour
c'est denis therrien un autre emploi
penalty vers et il devient le corps
quelqu'un c'est une tune qui centrale de
chine était normalement c'est pour cela
que c'est plus dangereux de sa défense
qu'est ce que cette pluie jusqu'au jour
où arrive la bonne crise
et voila voila le résultat toronto nyon
ça vous amuse toi l'homme et c'est beau
mais vous comprenez première est ici
fort essentiel 5 pc ça va ça va mal
finir
alors nous allons écouter moi je suis
pas idiot à vous serez à la stabilité
vous la voyez c'est l'une des
manifestations ouais alors il parle des
mariages tendez la main
dames oui comme ça c'est pour quoi faire
voyez vous le voyez vous le tremblement
alcoolique
c'est un des symptômes les fêtards
observé m
attention et vous foutez moi d'amour fou
qu'est ce qui m'a dit monsieur vous êtes
un programme devant mon vieux voyons
même ray si vous avez eu à plérin de les
faire partir un petit salle escorté par
le jeu bienveillante et c'est qu'il sait
que ces gens là me surprend un peu marre
tombé un peu partout on ne marque pas un
gars qui se digère un peu marre tu auras
thomas retourne
bah ouais mais alors là il fallait me
prévenir fric
il fallait me glisser tout bois il son
look fun
ici vous avez à me prendre la main ou
rien c'est par amitié at on pas dit
ouais ouais me réponds d'aller pêcher si
c'est avec les bright food aujourd'hui
reconnue mais c'est curieux vous n'avez
pas ce que partout ouais je dis vous
l'avez il a presque pas toute sa vie la
montagne est aussi pompier way
elle fait rire maintenant qu'on a bien
ri on va être un réseau de free je suis
un ami tout près c'est non ah bon
dans la chute d'octobre le bon docteur
c'est moi qui soit une bobo maladie
s'inquiète le bon docteur bah oui quoi
et shippagan m6 docteur voilà voilà
mekhissi la paire l'idiome était bien je
sens enfin je sens mon goût regardons
que vous voulez c'est très tranquille et
ouais tu si vous êtes fatigué fatigué
mais je suis fatigué baledent ben il
était petit cécile je tiens ma place est
versée le coeur bat les hôtels motels
beaux pièges sur le parquet du matin au
dai ichi life est malade à mourir
je ne savais pas les avis vous
déshabiller et vous coucher ouais vous
allez au moins retirer cette jaquette
par lequel vous êtes mal dès qu'il vous
apporte une robe de chambre bien
confortable le dépit et m'a livré mais
oui oui mais c'est en attendant
maintenant il ya par la laisser là les
métis il a affaire là contre huit au
total 22 mai l'avenir une bonne devant
norbert mêler des moulières vous y
pensez pas même si je chante prix que
j'en dise c'est bien si je vous dis
quelque chose je le dis donc un poil à
la halle cantine et votre quête d'amour
ici c'est pas pour dire mais vous vous
faites moins que vous
vous êtes une pâte homogène leur dit que
vous n'êtes pas bien maintenant
lézardrieux
c'est à dire que génère du coach est
désormais là c'est vrai que c'est
drôlement plus douillette la vivra vous
voyez pas même en rêve et maintenant
j'ai un petit coin qui me dit vous devez
avoir soif
mouais il héberge une petite n'est ce
pas très bien je vais vous faire donner
quelque chose à boire
non seulement ça vous paraîtra peut-être
pas très bon centre à laval et où des
26es sea du raid
ah oui oui plutôt plein air est craint
trop abîmés par la vie monsieur nous
allons préparer des coupes dans un verre
d'eau oui monsieur
et après quand il sera à dégriser vous
lui ferez prendre attendez je vous faire
une ordonnance monsieur william hill 2
co écrit elle à ses hôtes image de
monsieur ce bon alors mais avant
d'emmener le ramener le coût choisi
monsieur daniel rouhier à son tour une
aubaine c'est une aubaine connais mon
brave monsieur
une bonne harmonie
ça m'embête tenez vous soyez cocu qui
moi monsieur même si vous en avez dit
charge de suivre sur une prenez la soupe
c'est le concierge
même si elle promet qsssl au reste et
que ça sent fort mais que c'était
parfait mais comme ça c'est ce papier
est oui viendrait-il où il en est avec
wayne ne tarit pas si vite
yvonne a dit d'y aller mais quelqu'un me
mettez votre appareil en appel que je
vous en ai apporté mon heure
une voie est encore longue et vous
appliquer à tous pas la mâchoire ou et
eddy avait tant de temps que j'ai vécu à
colmar aujourd'hui et vous vous en
rendrez dans des verres et ouais et les
ont ils dit avec un collet bras en trop
pourquoi le pôle el ouata ou non et à
l'arménie dette et non à risque ils à
leurs vidéos ou des neiges où aller ni
où aller
[Musique]
monsieur mieux vous lui direz ce nom
plutôt j'ai fait moi-même mais qui là
encore rien n'est pas plus souffrants
bonsoir musique à me préparer l'ammoniac
pendant que je vais chez ma roue à eau
et si on estime que 2 mai à amen est
bien une jolie pub ballon et les numéros
oui oui oui
howard qui est il vous demande pardon
john howett
c'est bien le sujet d'aujourd'hui à
l'hôtel du minet galant un appel au
corps pour la personne
il avait une raison une aile en ont
jamais entendu ni avec personne mais qui
si la donne dans la galerie un mail
crachements le crash est très malade
rappelle 11e dédié à l'aller thl que y
avait une assurance héninois ici et je
m'en fiche de tout spécialement aux
heures de pointe non mais moi j'ai ce
crash de swat à la paix on m'avait dit
qu'on apporterez avoir payé combien pour
maintenir et à et a acquis sa dette
erro bat docteur noël
les leaders et j'avais mon 810 et ses
passagers la pépie pas résulter by terry
alors dès la trentaine un joyeux on
voyait rien n'est trop dû à la hanche
mesdames wyatt table pour le collège lui
y croyez mes filets et roanne il est là
prévient tiennent alors qu'est ce qui
les inquiète bien aller ou non
camille pas ça mais il bat la campagne
qu'est ce qu'ils attendent en est
aujourd'hui décidée à l'eau
bon dieu et satan tel quel cauchemar
quel coach me kane cause quelques sujets
qui avaient aimé jacquet de seine mais
qu'est ce qu'il a apporté
enfin c'est pas trop tôt que je quitte
cette livrée
quand je pense que j'ai été obligé de
rentrer dans cette tenue
le concierge je me reconnaissais même
pas lui ne voulait que je monte par
l'escalier de service
j'ai roulé
mais pas encore fini escale chez camille
à ça je me le demande et tiennent au
fait comment ça si je vous reconnais non
mais dites non mais vous plaisantez
mais pourquoi ne vous connaîtraient pas
je ne sais pas parce que je ne sais pas
[Musique]
c'est nous mon ami nous tous ici et tout
d'un coup du territoire je vous ai chopé
de là-bas dans cette boîte 1 ère l'homme
explique et qu'on m'explique qua non
mais y croyez vous et nous payer ma tête
comme ça je vous en prie foutez moi la
paix
[Musique]
nous voyons mon vieux chante 10 a
longtemps je vous demande pardon ou cher
finage spasm band
je suis laissé aller à un mouvement de
colère mais elle est donc c'est un
exutoire
si ça doit vous faire du bien ça pascal
mais il ya déjà un mieux sensible
vous commencez à reconnaître les
chiffres à savoir qui vous quoi pas
mieux commencer à reconnaître les gens
et à savoir qui je suis à ça mais dit on
vous aussi non non mais est ce que c'est
une scie donc est-ce que j'ai pour
habitude de ne pas reconnaître les gens
et de ne pas savoir qui je suis
non non au passage ils vont l'emporter
mais j'ai toute ma raison vous savez
j'ai un lien secret bien à bord
seulement tout de même voilà votre place
je serais resté couché quoi bon ça quel
besoin aviez vous de remettre votre
jaquette mais vous êtes pauvres parce
que j'en avais assez de premier en chine
pourquoi ils seront tous de ce baladeur
la manche et ses papilles le livret il
livré à moi à moi l'univers
voilà l'idée fixe ça j'en aurais vu de
toutes les couleurs avant tout être du
minet galant l'épousé vérité tiens vous
deviez pas y aller eh bien j ai des
voilà que de péripéties mon dieu conduit
par ces travaux le patron fou on enfonce
une livre est enfermé dans une chambre
obligé de me sauver par et toi j'ai
failli me rompre le cou et brochon sur
le tout branché sur le tout amélie
dhesse non j'ai tout d'ailleurs j'oublie
vous savez absolument tout ou absolument
qu'il est malade mon dieu qu'il est mal
à gaza je m'en souviendrai
voilà compris un monsieur supporteurs et
bien monsieur l'auteur de cette plante
un deux trois mois failli le battre en
mieux aux mureaux notre nom pour nom que
le délire le détail 8
cela vous est souvent le serveur mail
eaux vives à qui ça moi oui après aux
émotions ça va mettre ça n'est pas non
plus d'ailleurs parce que la colère de
toutes leurs malles terreau et j'en
étais certain seulement c'est un peu
fort alors avalé d'un seul coup world
vous avait prévenu sa fille regarde vers
l'italie
[Applaudissements]
mais qu'est ce que ça fait un très petit
nombre la défense de mauvais goût mais
foutez moi la paix quand j'ouvre mais
moi les gens commencent à vous je vais
mais morale c'est la volt est d'octroyer
cette agréable avoue sa détient tout
craché c'est comme si on n'avait rien
fait hors sérail ont par exemple mes
entraîneurs m'ont mené pour votre
assurance pour un enjeu de classe je ne
sais pas permis non je passerai un de
ces matins pour ça non je viens pour
rapporter un objet qui a été trouvé à
mon notaire et qui appartient à monsieur
camille chante bise
je reconnais c'est moi qui l'ait trouvée
etienne dans les échanges mises en
chantier repasse avec montrez moi ça
mais oui mais c'est le palais de camille
comment il perd son panneau envie
maintenant voilà de l'ordre mais comment
avez-vous su que c'était à lui atteint
le nom et l'adresse qui sont gravées à
l'intérieur non ah oui camille 95
boulevard malesherbes mais cette
intelligence arrêt aux puits très
commode quand on a oublié ses cartes de
vis en live longtemps je lui en ai grâce
à qui tu viens de trouver demain tout nu
on traite pas pris une douche quoi qu
est-ce qu il ya encore au bouche à 7
heures dans l'eau c'est de la folie le
wallaby cabinet voir il prend le tout on
l'apprend l'idée de cet incident
et bien bonne celle-là on prépare notre
enfant c'est bien la libre mais sa
casquette bien bonne celle-là avait
commencé ici mon garçon est donc venu
chez vous quand un garçon au non
monsieur pourquoi serait-il venu à
quelle heure tout ce beau monde le fait
il est il est parti j'ai eu l'heureuse
idée de claquer la porte d'entrée comme
c'est la coutume juillet paris
oui oui on me laisse mon avis une
économie à yuma l'échappée cette auto
may et voilà tout
et sans les choses qui m'ont arrêté et
conduit à la commissionnaire de police
et vous allez faire connaître ce que
c'est qu'un revolver
les commissionnaires de police une
maquette fiscale en revolver il m'a fait
promettre comme la lâcheté km et s'est
levé pour les heures il est promis à
brave commissionnaires alors y apporter
oui les pistols un non non non mais
n'ayez pâquerettes
y'avait pas vous suicider
il est l'époux faire un momento comment
vous dites en français elle flagrante
des littoraux mais j'ai compris que oui
maintenant je serai ou de m dieu ne
rompt pas à l'utiliser aussi alors là il
ya portait un pistolet en main des
chargées et ne tenait pas et ben là
j'aime mieux le premier je prends un
morceau de craie y est fait en rond sur
votre corps un mets donc mais fusion
entre évasion jamais fait les mêmes pour
moi il a été d'ailleurs y ait plein les
pistolets oui chacun les canons dans les
rendre des comptes au sol et qui à la
base il est morte à l'essai et l'autre
c'est les doigts les déchets nous
n'allons pas vous savez où aller
voilà un pistolet quoi prévient pistolet
trajet vous dis non merci moi vous savez
je ne prends jamais rien entre les
hommes puissent pratiquer fait les mêmes
c'est sérieux mais voulez vous prendre
le départ à l'aide
là moi je suis là couché d'amender sa
vie à la maison est hantée mon vieux
pistolet au diplôme le plus petit est
fou il ya quelques tours y était témoin
y aller tu es là pistolet et petit pont
et hélas la parole est revenue aux
citoyens les misérables s'est fait du
mal à pistol est petit pourriez vous
êtes pour vous ils étaient tous même
temps
ce coup là
le soleil a brillé
ayvaz ces points non il va bien il est
là qu elle y allait tous les ghettos et
sk
mais qu'est-ce qui présente des salles
de type comme ça dans la maison
qu'est-ce qui sont ici et parfums de la
lettre la fin de ma femme
le papier au pied de la lettre et les
bijoux exclu madame monsieur y est vous
avez vu le palais royal sait la doule de
la reine marie bockel est dans la poche
mais pourquoi dans la capitale et de
madame jeanne devises il faut que je
sache ils sont les poubelles pouvait et
donc la question s'est déroulé du tout
ma famille confection monsieur bull la
lettre les éléments c'est moi louis saha
ont là dessus vous m'aidez la tête à
l'envers alors que tout ça devrait être
fait pour vous prouver la parfaite
innocence de votre femme comment comment
comme monde parce qu'elle est à supposer
que s'il y avait la moindre intrigue
entre votre femme et mon mari ça ne
serait vraiment pas de mapa peut trier
mes joueurs s'échangent de rayong etc
etc etc etc etc il est né voici votre
femme
voulant prudemment vous pouvez
maintenant utiliser cette année vingt
cas il peut me donner papier scep
annoncera le ciel de nuit l'acte et deux
seraient but pour le repos de ses
ménages
on s'installe à paris entend bien venir
ici on vient s'y inscrire pour la faire
face on a ri de rester en vie à l'heure
des conneries dans tous les scrutins la
pièce est un mélange très bien sous le
regard on l'espère est ce qu a dit c'est
mais tout ce qui a pu perdre en seniors
enseigne en fin de matinée cet été là on
fait un temps avec l ina il se sublimer
sa capitale espagnole
moi moi je me suis trouvé nez à nez avec
moi-même dans cette chambre
écoutez le monde et quelques années
maintenant
maintenant qu'il sait que l'auteur de la
lettre bayal sall mais pas ensemble
c'est la bête un toit c'est la 40e fois
contre le dit wang qishan france
s'embrase puis a rien de fait mais enfin
mais qu'est ce qu'est ce qui est dit et
les tirs que pour ça vous avez sauté par
la fenêtre
voilà ce n'est même plus une émotion
comment ça de moi mais vous m'avez fait
sauter par la fenêtre veillée de l'avent
et vous avez sauté en pas mal commencé à
y est ça y est lui aussi nous sommes
tous le choix du domaine hallucinations
ce que vous avez vu sauter par la
fenêtre et qui me ressemblaient c'est ce
que j'ai vu moi dans mon élan wahaha est
absolument d'ailleurs la preuve c'est
que je suis bien certain de n'avoir
jamais jamais son départ cette fois
c'est de la féerie de la filière ans
je demande pardon mesdames et messieurs
le fou alors mes instants le passé dans
la rue j'ai failli recevoir sur la tête
mon garçon d'hôtel qui sont des deux ne
sait pourquoi
par cette fenêtre à edel carter et qui
filait en en portant ce vêtement mais
c'est à mon mari c'est à toi t'es pas
utile il tend emmanuel rythme annuel
[Applaudissements]
mais cette unité 6e chaîne lui chaque
fois qu'on se rencontre et le floch une
roulotte allées lui sent debise
parfaitement impossible lui cette part
restera tant de poche mon garçon d'hôtel
paul oui celui là même qui sont l
instant par cette fenêtre
1 je comprends tout maintenant l'homme
que j'ai vu tout à l'heure et qui peut
ressembler cette époque que nous avons
bel et bien là c'est moche poche
toujours poche
à part le ca je regrette qu'ils défient
des civils bon sosie ça j'aurais pu le
voir de près mais rien de moyens
monsieur d'affaires patients de ces
journaux tels des mines eagle mois
l'otage il est à l'enjeu c'est un non
non non ça il m'a s'est vu lui même pas
pour les beaux yeux de l'inconnu du
fabricant voyons mais je te conseille de
te moquer en avant dans le jeu pièces et
légumes et des fleurs
je doutais de ta fidélité ben moi mais
dieu bon pourquoi mais parce que pour
sue peu bidon à cause de ceci peut
bomber 1 qu'est ce que tu veux c'est
bête ça m'avait mis la puce à l'oreille
sacré puces basse et bien je la tuerais
ce soir
enfin je j'essaierai l'a écouté tes
mômes employé demain
[Musique]
on
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
à
oh
[Musique]